First reactions to The Rise of Skywalker were
mostly positive but clearly mixed.
Now, it's time to dive into the full-length
reviews to see how critics truly feel about
what director and co-writer J.J. Abrams did
with the final installment of the Skywalker
saga.
Warning: mild spoilers ahead!
Of the reviews on Rotten Tomatoes that register
as "Rotten", that is, ones accompanied by
ratings below 60 percent a large portion of
them take issue with the general feeling of
forced wish-granting woven throughout the
film.
This is to say that many critics were displeased
by the fact that The Rise of Skywalker feels
like it's pandering to the audience including
people who were angry with the events of writer-director
Rian Johnson's The Last Jedi, a Star Wars
installment that divided fans and caused them
to bicker with critics who praised the film
for the past two years.
"The beginning of their end.
Destroy it!"
Michael O'Sullivan of The Washington Post
was one of a number of critics conflicted
over the fan service crammed into The Rise
of Skywalker, arguing that the film "panders
wildly" and concludes the Skywalker saga,
quote, "with a story that delivers to the
faithful exactly the movie they wanted", which
may or may not be a good thing.
He wrote in his review,
"Everybody wants a happy ending.
But that doesn't mean that we should always
get the one we want.
It's fine, if also cliche, to be reminded
that good will triumph over evil.
But it would make for a deeper and more powerful
lesson one that, after nine movies, might
leave a lasting dent in the heart if the hero
actually had to give up something, or someone,
that didn't feel like a tiniest bit of a cop-out."
The Film Stage critic Jordan Raup wrote that
The Rise of Skywalker is the antithesis to
The Last Jedi, in that it doesn't take many
risks and undoes a lot of what preceded it.
He wrote,
"A direct contradiction to Johnson's repeated
mantra of letting old things die, this ninth
and final film in the series is wholly about
the desire to uncover the past to unlock one's
true identity and honor the generations and
iconic characters that came before.
By lacking a sense of vision in embracing
what came before and ignoring the recently
laid path for where this story could go, The
Rise of Skywalker is not only a disappointing
end to this saga, it's also an ill-fated harbinger
for Disney's future in storytelling."
Other critics agreed with Raup's point that
The Rise of Skywalker plays it safe and doesn't
take the risks that it could have, decisions
that many feel are to the film's detriment.
USA Today's Brian Truitt, who gave The Rise
of Skywalker two-and-a-half stars out of four,
wrote in his review,
"It's impressively ambitious, though great
new personalities and fresh storytelling suffer
for the sake of fan service...Some of the
liberties Rian Johnson's Last Jedi took with
the nostalgic Star Wars status quo are rethought
here, so get ready for a disturbance in the
fandom."
Over at Slate, Sam Adams wrote that Abrams
attempted to "make a movie no one would hate"
instead of one that some might love, resulting
in a film that's only satisfying because it's
been "force-fed" to viewers.
He added,
"The haste with which The Rise of Skywalker
rushes to undo its predecessor is almost comical
at first, at least before its capitulation
to the franchise's most toxic fans turns outright
contemptible."
In other less-than-great reviews of The Rise
of Skywalker, a common gripe was that the
film comes across confused and messy.
Dan Murrell of Screen Junkies said in his
video review,
"There seems to have been absolutely no road
map as to what these movies were going to
be, and it shows."
Meanwhile, Uproxx senior entertainment reporter
Mike Ryan argued that the film is perplexing,
clumsy, and totally overstuffed, writing,
"J.J. Abrams' Star Wars: The Rise of Skywalker
is the most convoluted of all the Star Wars
movies.
It feels like three full movies worth of plot
crammed into one film.
The stories in the other Star Wars movies,
even the Prequels, have a way of bringing
a viewer into that world.
Star Wars: The Rise of Skywalker never lets
us in.
It, instead, keeps us at arms length so it
can use almost its entire first half as exposition.
Just character after character explaining
things."
Ryan also felt that The Rise of Skywalker
panders to a certain type of Star Wars fan,
adding,
"There were times it felt like The Rise of
Skywalker was put together by reading angry
Reddit boards, just throwing in anything a
fan might possibly want to see.
It really is baffling."
Over at Vanity Fair, Richard Lawson expanded
on the point Ryan brought up, writing in his
review,
"There doesn't seem to be any real organic
idea animating Rise of Skywalker; instead
it feels cobbled together from notes stuffed
in the suggestion boxes of Reddit and Twitter...I
don't think Rise of Skywalker is ill-intentioned,
exactly...but it takes no pleasure in its
own existence."
Where there are detractors, there are also
cheerleaders, and The Rise of Skywalker has
plenty of enthusiastic critics rallying behind
it, ones who had no trouble giving the film
flawless five-out-of-five-star reviews and
praising it as a satisfying conclusion to
the four-decade-long Star Wars story.
Jordan Hoffman at The Guardian was one such
critic who stamped The Rise of Skywalker with
a perfect rating, writing,
"The movie snaps together like a jigsaw puzzle,
a series of concluding beats that seem inevitable
and perfect, and designed to please all parties,
so long as you don't dwell on the logic too
much."
Newsday's Rafer Guzmán gave the film three
out of four stars, and said that the main
takeaway is that, quote, "after more than
40 years, the Star Wars series comes in for
a smooth landing."
Richard Roeper at The Chicago-Sun Times had
even more kind things to say about The Rise
of Skywalker, though he ultimately felt the
film was really good but not great, writing,
"The Rise of Skywalker is an action-filled,
plot-packed, unabashedly sentimental, cameo-heavy,
rousing adventure.
The special effects are as fantastic as you'd
expect them to be.
The performances are earnest and, in some
cases, emotionally impactful...The Rise of
Skywalker rarely comes close to touching greatness,
but it's a solid, visually dazzling and warmhearted
victory for the Force of quality filmmaking."
Someone who did feel The Rise of Skywalker
is capital-F fantastic was The Seattle Times'
Soren Andersen, who wrote in part,
"Epic it indeed is, full of magnificent set
pieces sprawling space battles and incandescent
lightsaber duels gripping performances and
a number of truly stunning surprises."
Digital Spy's Ian Sandwell was noticeably
impressed by The Rise of Skywalker, calling
it an "emotional, thrilling, and satisfying
end to the Skywalker Saga, with plenty of
surprises up its sleeve."
He wrote,
"The Rise of Skywalker shines with emotional
beats that fans won't forget, as well as crowd-pleasing
payoffs that have been decades in the making...Given
the task that Abrams faced when he returned
to the franchise, Star Wars: The Rise of Skywalker
is an impressive achievement.
It won't please everybody, of course, but
there will be plenty who find it ends the
Skywalker Saga on a high."
So it sounds like some people are going to
love The Rise of Skywalker, and some people
are going to hate The Rise of Skywalker, which
is no big surprise.
If you find yourself in the latter camp, take
heart: A new episode of The Mandalorian airs
December 27th!
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Star Wars
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.